[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: 10 things
game developers
should know-- this is
the third time I've
done this talk in
GDC-- especially
if they want to get featured.
So let's start with Android
design applies to you,
or at least
considerate it, mostly.
What we mean is you don't
have to use flat sprites,
but you should take a look at
the core app quality guidelines
we have on
developer.android.com.
And especially look at
things like launcher
icons, because it's the most
important asset for your brand.
Please consider not making
it a rounded rectangle.
It's not required
on our platform.
Also, look at navigation
[? in ?] handling
the back key, because
even if your UX looks
completely custom,
the back key better
work in a reasonable way.
Phones sometimes
have hardware keys.
And notifications--
the featuring team
hates spammy notifications.
Your application should not
use more than one notification
at a time as a guideline.
And you should combine
notifications on Jelly Bean
and above.
Two, support the new
stuff and the old stuff.
What do we mean by this?
In your manifest, always
support the latest version
you have tested against.
This turns off any
compatibility hacks
that might slow
your performance,
and the [? featured ?]
committee likes it.
But of course, if you're
using an NDK application,
your app platform must be less
than or equal to your min SDK
version, because this
is a C++ ABI after all,
so we don't have
forward compatibility.
Three, using immersive mode.
One of the new features
you might want to use
is immersive mode
when it makes sense.
If you're not doing
an immersive game,
you probably don't
need immersive mode.
So it just makes a potentially
confusing navigation
experience your players
when the nav bar disappears.
But if you have some
awesome real time space
simulation that would benefit
from immersive mode, go for it.
Four, support cloud save.
It doesn't have to be
ours-- any cloud save.
But your users will
really appreciate it.
And of course, it's
nice if it's ours.
You get all sorts
of great features,
along with Play Game services.
And we call this Saved
Games, really creatively.
Five, respect user privacy.
What we mean here is
minimize permissions, OK?
So I used to talk about the
top 10 bad game permissions.
There's really no bad list.
But if you're using
anything like this,
you probably don't
have a good reason.
And if your middleware
requires it,
you probably shouldn't
be using that middleware.
Finally, make sure that you
understand when the advertising
ID can and must be used.
Remember that you really are
responsible for any middleware
your game uses.
Six, play by the
rules of Google Play.
Speaking of advertising
ID, take a close look
at your developer distribution
agreement and your program
policies.
Read these policies.
Remember that our
enforcement team
deals with thousands
of infractions daily
and has little patience
with the bad guys.
So if you think what
you're doing is even
violating the spirit of
these policies, think again.
All right.
Seven, controls.
Be flexible with your controls.
For example, on
developer.android.com,
we've got this fantastic
example of what standard button
mapping looks like.
So consider
supporting game pads.
And also consider both
phones and tablets
when designing touch controls.
Just because my screen
is bigger doesn't
mean my fingers are longer.
And of course, think of TVs.
This means you shouldn't
require touch at all.
And you consider supporting
D-pads, at least in your menus.
Eight, size matters, always.
So this is our Nexus 6.
It is our biggest,
baddest phone,
and it has 64 gigs of
onboard storage, up to.
That's still not enough.
It has a whopping
three gigs of memory.
That's also not enough.
So smaller APKs tend
to get more downloads.
Use things like multi APK and
GPU Native Texture formats
to keep things small in memory.
Use WebP, a distribution
size, as your highest concern.
Consider hosting
assets for post install
to make the initial
download size smaller.
The size in Flash matters, too.
OK?
Because people will delete
things that are big.
On lower memory devices,
adapt by using Native Texture
formats.
Finally, we can't make
batteries much larger.
Keep people playing
the game more
by avoiding excessive
network use and wake locks.
If you need to
keep the screen on,
use a window flag,
not a wake lock.
Nine, testing.
Don't panic.
Use the matrix.
As you can see, with the
matrix, it's just five devices.
We've tested three screen size
buckets, five resolutions,
four memory configurations,
five GPUs, five CPUs
from five different
manufacturers.
It's not that hard.
10, have fun.
Build great games.
And what do I mean
when I say that?
Well, here is an example
of a featured list
from a current
Google Play session.
And if you take a look
at these, they all
have something in common.
Users love them.
Ultimately, we want to
promote games both we
and our users love.
So that's it-- 10 things that
will help you build games
that your users will love
and that Google Play will
want to feature.
All right?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]